die inflationsrate liegt im mai bei fast
acht prozent waren und dienstleistungen
kosteten durchschnittlich 79 mehr als
noch vor einem jahr das hat das
statistische bundesamt soeben in einer
ersten schätzung mitgeteilt und von
reuters befragte ökonomen die hatten ja
nur mit 7,6 prozent gerechnet nach 7,4
prozent im april seit beginn des
russischen angriffskrieges gegen die
ukraine vor drei monaten sind die
energiepreise merklich gestiegen und
hinzu kommen natürlich auch noch
lieferengpässe durch unterbrochenen
lieferketten aufgrund der korona
pandemie ziemlich dramatische
entwicklung über die wir sprechen müssen
mit bildpolitik schäfer jan schäfer 7,9
prozent jahren das ist absolut irre muss
man sagen christian lindner hat jetzt
heute auch schon steuerentlastungen
angekündigt aber glaubst du dass das
jetzt reichen wird angesichts dieser 19
7,9 prozent sind der höchste stand seit
fast 50 jahren das muss man sich
vorstellen wir haben doch gerade eben
eingeblendet gesehen inflations hammer
das ist ein echter inflations hammer und
wir finden es eigentlich jetzt in so
etwas wie eine teufelsspirale der wenn
wir einmal auf die gründe schauen warum
jetzt vieles teurer wird dann werden wir
feststellen es ist nicht nur der ukraine
krieg und da sind nicht nur lieferketten
probleme die wir sehen weil
beispielsweise in china häfen wegen
eines lecks geschlossen sind nein wir
sehen natürlich auch energie ist teurer
geworden schreibt deswegen die preise
dadurch werden löhne steigen
beispielsweise auch die mindestlohn
erhöhung im herbst dieses jahres das
heißt das macht natürlich viele waren
noch mal wieder teurer und deswegen wird
es so schnell mit diesem teuer schock
auch nicht vorbei sein wir sind aber
jetzt auf einem echten spitzenwert fast
auf ein 50 jahres hoch und die frage
christian lindner mit steuer senken das
ist eine möglichkeit um den teuer schock
ein bisschen abzumildern aber es ist
natürlich wenig zu tun für die politik
zur zeit schauen wir mal auf diese
tatsächliche entwicklung in den letzten
monaten wir haben auch noch mal eine
kleine grafik vorbereitet da sehen wir
tatsächlich eine steigerung 2 prozent im
april 21 und dann geht es immer weiter
rauf jan zwischendurch im januar 22 dann
4,9 prozent im april dann 74 und jetzt
eben fast acht prozent
ein echter hammer und du sagst eben es
erklärt sich tatsächlich eben durch
verschiedenste instrumente aber wie kann
man diese inflation jetzt auch wieder
rückgängig machen oder stoppen oder geht
das gar nicht das ist jetzt im aktuellen
modus schwer und ein großes versäumnis
das liegt bei der notenbank bei der
europäischen zentralbanken ja über
monate auch im letzten jahr als absehbar
war dass wir wirklich in so eine
inflationsspirale eine teufelsspirale
rein steuern immer eigentlich gesagt hat
nein das wird alles nicht so schlimm
sein wird alles nicht so schlimm es gab
viele ökonomen gerade hier in
deutschland die heimlich gesagt haben
achtung achtung leid ihr müsst etwas tun
wir laufen hier auf eine schlimme
inflation zu die immer immer höher wird
so und gibt es das kind eigentlich im
brunnen das entscheidende sind auch
immer die erwartungen wird es noch
teurer wird es nicht teurer wir sehen
das ganz ganz viele firmen mehr als die
hälfte in deutschland auch in den
nächsten monaten ihre preise noch
erhöhen wollen das bedeutet natürlich
die inflation wird weitergehen es wird
so weitergehen ob es jetzt eine acht
gibt oder eine 7 das ist dann am ende
egal wir sehen zurzeit die fast höchste
inflation seit 50 jahren das wird
anhalten und was bedeutet das auch ganz
kurz für unsere deutsche wirtschaft wie
wird sie damit fertig werden
preiserhöhung preiserhöhungen das
schlimme ist wird dann seien aus sicht
der unternehmen und der verbraucher auch
die löhne werden steigen freut die
arbeitnehmer verständlich ist auch
sicherlich richtig aber das ist genau
dieser teufelskreislauf der dann in gang
kommt in höhere löhne bedeuten am ende
auch wieder höhere preise und damit wird
die inflation weiter weiter steigen
keine gute entwicklung und keine guten
aussichten dankeschön für seine
einschätzung